alors l'état madame nathalie kosciusko
morizet merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre notre
assemblée a voté cette nuit là
prorogation de l'état d'urgence mais
nous savons déjà que ce texte est
insuffisant le terrorisme prospère sur
un terreau fertile le salafisme les
salles de prière secret des mosquées
sont prises en main par des individus
qui prêchent la haine la supériorité de
la loi religieuse sur les lois de la
république et la soumission des femmes
est ce une opinion est ce une religion
ou n'est ce pas plutôt une dérive
sectaire de l'islam responsable de la
radicalisation parfois jusqu au
terrorisme et au meurtre
il est temps de déclarer le seul un fils
hors la loi comme dérives sectaires ou
comme atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux
de la nation choisissons la voie la plus
sûre déclaré le salafisme
hors la loi c'est donner une base solide
à la fermeture des mosquées qui prêchent
la haine et ses dires du même mouvement
que ceux qui pratiquent paisiblement
leur religion n'ont rien à voir avec
cela cette mesure évidemment doit
s'inscrire dans le cadre d'une politique
globale pour l'émergence d'un islam de
france respectueux des lois de la
république à l'islam enfin débarrassé
des influences étrangères et donc des
financements notamment ceux du qatar et
l'arabie saoudite
il existe des solutions j'en ai proposé
une avec la création d'une redevance sur
le halal d'autres sont possibles comme
celles proposées par nos sens notre
ancien collègue gérald darmanin
débattent 11 ans mais monsieur le
ministre sortons de l'hypocrisie
actuelle qui laisse prospérer dans nos
cités une idéologie que nous dénonçons
par ailleurs et qui sert aujourd'hui de
terreau au terrorisme
monsieur le premier ministre votre
gouvernement soutiendra-t-il un projet
ou une proposition de loi visant à
mettre enfin le salafisme hors la loi
merci la parole est à mathieu le premier
ministre manuel valls
madame la ministre je veux d'abord
rappeler une vérité je réponds bien sûr
un une question opportune et
intéressante
le salafisme est une minorité de l'islam
de france on compte je vous le rappelle
ce qui n'est pas négligeable dans notre
pays s'était dit hier d'ailleurs un peu
plus de 120 lieux de culte salafistes
sur plus de 2000 3000 2300 mosquée et
seulement et seulement quelques dizaines
de milliers de fidèles
et puis par ailleurs le fondamentalisme
d'intégrisme le procès repas uniquement
sur le salafisme j'y reviendrai
oui numériquement le salafisme ne
représente pas un courant fort mais
idéologiquement
c'est une minorité agissante qui gagnent
des batailles ces messages sont diffusés
des mosquées sont déstabilisés et il
porte notamment sur internet une
stratégie d'expansion
j'étais peut-être le premier à le dire
ici dans cette enseigne peu importe ce
n'est pas le sujet mais j'étais le
premier à le dire cette idéologie
intégriste qui rejette la démocratie qui
ne reconnaît aucune souveraineté qui
rejette et qui combat nos valeurs
universelles et qu'il reconnaît donc
aucune souveraineté haute que la
religion leur religion est une idéologie
violente qu'il faut évidemment combattre
parce que le salafisme
c'est la négation du vivre ensemble
c'est une idéologie qui retranche la
femme du monde qui propagent des idées
dangereuses perverse rétrograde oui le
salafisme qui a détruit et pervertit une
partie du monde musulman est un danger
pour les musulmans eux-mêmes et donc un
danger aussi pour la france pour le
combattre vous avez évoqué la question
des sectes poursuivront cependant le
débat mais je ne suis pas sûr ce soit le
bon outil
d'une part vous le savez madame la
députée il n'y a pas de définition des
sectes endroit d'autre part ces
organisations c'est parfait
m'en échapper à la justice en
dissimulant le véritable nature car vous
n'ignorez pas que la liberté de
conscience en france est une liberté
fondamentale consacré par tous nos
principes et nos textes
et puis je dis aussi attention je
reconnais que faut approfondir le débat
à tout signe qu'il y serait à penser
qu'il y à une déresponsabilisation que
ceux qui plongent dans le salafisme
serait en quelque sorte les victimes
d'une grande manipulation comme pour ce
qui concerne les sexes non il ya aussi
cette part de volonté personnelle qu'il
ne faut jamais écarté sinon on passe à
côté de l'essentiel le combat contre le
salafisme le combat contre le
fondamentalisme le combat contre
l'intégrisme et je fait écho aussi aux
interventions de bruno le maire sur
l'islam politique ou de malek boutih
nouvelle fois sur lierre soir sur la
radicalisation sur le radicalisme cas le
frère musulman comme le salafisme sont
au coeur de ces idéologies qui ont
prospéré et avant de prospérer de notre
pays dans d'autres pays regardons ce qui
s'est passé objectivement en egypte et
donc l'islam de france a aussi tout son
rôle à jouer
les musulmans français ont leur part ou
leur part et nous devons les aider les
ont corrigé dans la défense de la
république à eux aussi bien sûr avec
notre soutien de mener le combat pour
clairement séparés ce qui est la réalité
de l'islam de france et ses idéologies
perverse
ce combat doit être mené partout dans
les mosquées dans les quartiers dans les
familles sans aucune complaisance de la
manière la plus claire et la plus nette
ici nous savons c'est de notre
responsabilité nous devons protéger tous
nos compatriotes et nous devons aussi
bien sûr protéger nos compatriotes
musulmans les concitoyens musulmans
les compatriotes et concitoyens
musulmans ou de culture musulmane dans
notre pays qui aujourd'hui ont aussi
peur et qui se sentent montrés du doigt
et qui voit bien les dégâts
considérables non seulement évidemment
et les attentats mais que recherchent
des ch en
actu rang la société française a eu
aussi à cet islam de france en europe et
dans le monde de prendre totalement ses
responsabilités en tout cas nous sommes
prêts bien évidemment à étudier tous les
moyens qui existent pour non seulement
réduire l' influence de cet islam
politique du salafisme ou des frères
musulmans avec la plus grande
détermination
merci monsieur le premier ministre